webber mit einem jahr nicht so intensiv
wahrnehmen können und reißmüller konnte
vielleicht kann ja jemand die deutsche
einheit auf die tagesordnung der
weltpolitik setzen da ist ja ich sage es
braucht jetzt noch einmal 30 jahre ein
knaller
also damit jeder besitzer des passes
überhaupt erst mal ausgegeben werden wir
wollten aber jetzt bin ich ja nicht
ändern als sich aus er ist hier das
tritt nach meiner kenntnis ist das
sofort unverzüglich das war die berühmte
pressekonferenz von günter schabowski am
9 november 1989
es war aber nicht dieser versprecher der
die grenze öffnete es musste so kommen
es hatte sich abgezeichnet der druck im
kessel war so gross das war allenfalls
der tropfen der das fass zum überlaufen
brachte
was heute gern vergessen wird die
wiedervereinigung deutschland zwar
verfassungsauftrag das heißt schon mit
gründung dieses westdeutschen
teilstaates bundesrepublik deutschland
war im grundgesetz als provisorium
gedacht festgelegt die wiedervereinigung
ist das ziel dieses staates ist wurde
ist staatsziel starts zweck gerade die
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung hat sich
stets für die wiedervereinigung stark
gemacht
hier haben wir die ausgabe der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung vom 9
märz 1988 und unser damaliger
politischer ausgeber johann georg
kreisler schreibt einen leitartikel mit
dem titel freiheit und einheit und in
diesem artikel wird ein satz des
damaligen bundeskanzlers helmut kohl
erwähnt der da lautete zu dem zeitpunkt
die deutsche einheit steht nicht auf der
tagesordnung der weltpolitik und
reißmüller kommt hat vielleicht kann ja
jemand die deutsche einheit auf die
tagesordnung der weltpolitik setzen
ein knaller den kohl ihm angeblich noch
lange übel genommen hat
der leitartikel freiheit und einheit
stammt aus dem jahr 1988 und im selben
jahr also ein jahr vor dem fall der
mauer wurde ein kollege geboren mit
denen wir jetzt sprechen werden um zu
schauen was für auswirkungen hatte die
wiedervereinigung der fall der mauer die
ddr auf die nachfolgende generation
das hier ist simon strauß redakteur im
feuilleton was bedeutet der 19 november
82 für dich also für mich ist das
erstmal ein unglaublich
unwahrscheinlicher moment also auch in
der rückschau ich habe ihn selber mit
einem jahr nicht so intensiv wahrnehmen
können sodass ich sozusagen aus
historischer perspektive er sie
sozusagen diesen kairos moment des
schicksalhaften daran sehe und und das
für eine jahr weltweit einen weltweiten
einfluss dieses dieses ereignis jahr hat
und wie viele ereignisse gibt es die
wirklich weltweiten einfluss gehabt
haben nicht also deswegen schaue das an
und bin demütig wenn ich das wirtschaft
wird die generation 88 hatte nur chancen
absoluten hatte keine last eigentlich
abgesehen von der das leben so schnell
nichts erben dass sie im vergleich zum
westen auch ärmer sind ja das schon dass
das prägt natürlich auch und man muss
eben entscheiden unterscheiden dabei
zwischen der politischen faktizität und
eben dieser irrationalen kulturellen
mentalen dimension geboren zu sein
in einer familie wo und zweifel war eben
die frage nach sieger und verlierer eine
rolle spielt also eltern die sich als
verlierer fühlen mussten erstmal was
heißt das für die kinder genau was heißt
es für die kinder und was bedeutet dass
damit aufzuwachsen nicht und immer
wieder erzählungen von
unterschiedlichkeit schon aufzuhören ich
war also worte die sich unterscheiden
habitus eigenschaften musikvorlieben
also es gibt ja schon das sind zwei
unterschiedliche länder gewesen und die
die in einem großen glücksmoment
zusammengefügt worden sind und ich
glaube eben dass man unter dem begriff
des traumatischen das jetzt nicht zu
radikal zu verstehen was ist ein
gewisses trauma ja schon war und dass
man da zeit braucht um das wirklich zu
verarbeiten nicht also jetzt gab es
schon 30 jahre mal genau jetzt gab's ja
ich will sagen braucht jetzt noch mal 30
jahre bevor wir die sache wirklich
soweit aus unserer
kollektiven gedächtnis verarbeitet haben
und und raus getrieben doch ein team aus
hessen gibt sondern gleich die alten
länder und nord süd und ja und dann
untersagen die größte chance der ja auch
für meine generation sich intensiv mit
europa zu beschäftigen als er die
identitäts vokabel nicht also dass man
sozusagen das ist ja etwas was sowohl
ost und west eigentlich als etwas
eigenes empfinden können diese
europäische einigung der ursprünglichen
von chur gedacht war zusammen mit der
mit der deutschen einigung die
integration in europa nicht und auch da
müssen wir etwas nachholen als eine
junge generation die wie du sagst nur in
freiheit eigentlich in die gemachten
wetten gesetzt wurde
also wir haben ja nicht dafür gekämpft
dass der gut das ist sozusagen abschied
die größte schwierigkeit für meine
generation wir sind in die gemachten
wetten gelegt worden beim wünsche ich
uns allen viel erfolg dabei aber dieser
mammut aufgabe das schon mit der inder
ist noch interessant einige schönsten
texte finde ich nach wie vor
und es muss uns doch gelingen dass die
sonja sowie schön aber so so schön wie
nie weil dort die manche haben ja auch
gesehen dass wir dann vergeben hätte
also wird das hirn am anfang an die
gesungen aber dann nicht